there was a lot of speculation about you
potentially going into the
administration as Treasury secretary was
it a job you were interested in did you
turn that job down welcome everybody
let's really be back here we started
this a little over two years ago and I
follow you here have been helping out
Detroit its you should be very proud of
what you've accomplished and I've always
been quite public about I don't think
I'm suited to be Secretary of Treasury I
love what I do I'm not ready to do
something else and I think it can add a
lot of value to America just doing what
I'm doing there we go that's that's the
answer so when I look now as recently as
September when I look back at when you
were talking about sort of what you
thought the next administration would be
and this is before I knew the outcome of
the election you said you thought it
would be very difficult for Wall Street
guys to get confirmed and to get it and
now we look at sort of the landscape we
have we have several Wall Street figures
some of them you know very well
including Gary Cohen from Goldman Sachs
Rex Tillerson from Exxon Mobil Steve
minuchin when you're looking at that
cast of people what do you think they're
gonna bring to the administration that's
different what's new that they're gonna
bring in terms of experience is this a
good thing yeah so obviously I was dead
wrong about you're not gonna see a Wall
Street person in Washington anytime soon
but you had a complete upheaval the
Republicans are in charge and the
Republicans that have not been
anti-business the way you've seen the
Democrats largely be anti business for
years I think if you are going to be a
president you should have the best
people sitting around the table I think
it's a mistake for the American public
to casas be told that if you work for
oil company work for a bank you work for
this that that automatically makes you
bad you want the best team and so you
know honestly I think it's a good thing
so I think a lot of these people are
very qualified people who want it who
are patriots they're gonna want to help
the country then I could try to help
their former company that's not what
they're gonna try to do they're good so
these are people deep knowledge that
hopefully will do a great job do you
think that now when you look at that
sort of shift in terms of Wall Street
that this is a bit of a reset moment for
the industry more broadly in terms of
what the American people are expecting
or what they're likely to see I think
it's a reset moment for how businesses
can be treated so I've always believed
145 million people working
America 125 million work for a private
enterprise 20 million work for
government ok we hold them in very high
regard firemen sanitation police
teachers but you know if you didn't have
the hundred 25 you couldn't pay for the
other 20 so I think business is a huge
positive elements of society and for you
know for years it's been you know beaten
downs if there are terrible people or
something like that so I think it's a
good reset Detroit is a perfect example
that you see where civic society
not-for-profits here government business
working together to improve the lives of
American citizens so yeah I think the
reset has a chance to do the same thing
if you can duplicate in what you're
doing in Detroit all around the country
you're gonna have a huge Renaissance